>> Tucker: KAMALA HARRIS IS
SPEAKING TONIGHT AT THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL CONVENTION.
SHE’S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
TECHNICALLY VICE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVEN’T SEEN HER REMARKS YET,
THEY HAVEN’T SENT US AN EARLY
COPY BUT WE ARE PRETTY SURE THEY
BOTH SOUND NOTHING LIKE THE
KAMALA HARRIS OF 2013.
WATCH THIS.
>> GOING AROUND WITH THESE
SIGNS, BUILD MORE SCHOOLS, LESS
JAILS.
WE WALK EVERYWHERE, BUILD MORE
SCHOOLS, LESS JAILS.
PUT MONEY INTO EDUCATION, NOT
PRISONS.
THERE IS FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM
WITH THAT APPROACH, IN MY
OPINION, AND IT’S THIS.
I AGREE WITH THAT CONCEPTUALLY.
BUT YOU HAVE NOT ADDRESSED THE
REASON I HAVE THREE PADLOCKS ON
MY FRONT DOOR.
THERE SHOULD BE SERIOUS AND
SEVERE AND SWIFT CONSEQUENCE TO
CRIME.
>> Tucker: SERIOUS AND SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES FOR CRIME?
TRIGGER WARNING, THAT SOUNDS
RACIST, OKAY?
IT DOES.
THAT’S A TOOL OF OPPRESSION AND
KAMALA HARRIS APPEARS TO HAVE
COME TO THAT CONCLUSION.
HERE SHE IS SPEAKING THIS
SUMMER, SEE IF YOU CAN SPOT THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> PART OF WHAT HAS BEEN UPSIDE
DOWN IN POLICING POLICY IN
AMERICA IS THAT WE HAVE CONFUSED
HAVING SAFE COMMUNITIES WITH
HIRING MORE COPS ON THE STREET.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU ARE A
BUSINESS OWNER, AN AMERICAN WHO
LIVES IN THE CITY AND IS AFRAID
OF GETTING KILLED IN A RIOT OR
HAVING YOUR STORE BURNED DOWN,
KAMALA HARRIS WANTS YOU TO SHUT
UP AND UNDERSTAND RACIAL JUSTICE
JUSTICE.
>> AND SO THE PEOPLE PROTESTING
ON THE STREET ARE PROTESTING,
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE YET
TO FULFILL THAT PROMISE OF EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
>> Tucker: KAMALA HARRIS HAS
CHANGED A LOT.
HOW?
WHY?
WHICH VERSION IS BETTER.
DANA PERINO IS IN WASHINGTON
TONIGHT FOR OUR CONVENTION
COVERAGE.
DANA, GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SO THE OLD KAMALA HARRIS OF 2013
I THINK IS MAYBE MORE IN LINE
WITH MOST AMERICANS.
BUT I WONDER IF WE’VE SOLVED FOR
THE REASON SHE’S GOT THREE
PADLOCKS ON HER FRONT DOOR.
TAPE LIKE THAT IS GOING TO IT
SEEMS TO ME STRIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE IS PRETTY SENSIBLE
COMPARED TO WHAT SHE’S SAYING
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE THAT’S AN INTERESTING
POINT BECAUSE I THINK IT WAS ON
YOUR SHOW, THERE WAS THE POLL,
THAT SAID THAT BLACK AMERICANS
ACTUALLY WANT MORE POLICE.
FEWER POLICE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THAT SECURITY MEANS THAT THEY
CAN DO ALL THE OTHER THINGS THEY
WANT TO DO, GET GOOD EDUCATION,
START BUSINESSES, RAISE HAPPY
FAMILIES.
HOWEVER, IF PEOPLE WANT TO
ATTACK HARRIS FROM THIS
PERSPECTIVE THAT SHE WAS A
REALLY TOUGH PROSECUTOR AND NOW
SHE’S PRETENDING THAT SHE
WASN’T, FOR PEOPLE THAT MAY BE
UNDECIDED OUR SUBURBAN WOMEN MAY
SAY THAT’S KIND OF REASONABLE TO
ME, THAT SOUNDS GOOD.
I THINK THE REPUBLICANS MAY
WANT, IF THEY WANT TO ATTACK HER
HER, WILL BE INTERESTING TONIGHT
IS IF YOU THINK, AOC IS THE
FUTURE OF THE PARTY AND
JOE BIDEN IS THE PAST, THEN
KAMALA HARRIS IS A PRESENT RIGHT
NOW AND THEY ARE CAUGHT BETWEEN
THAT IDEOLOGY TRANSFORMING AND
TRANSITIONING AND EVOLVING
BETWEEN WHERE SHE WAS EVEN IN
2011 AND WHERE SHE IS TODAY.
>> Tucker: SO REALLY QUICK,
THERE ARE REPORTS TONIGHT THAT
BARACK OBAMA IS JUST GOING TO
UNLEASH IN A WAY THAT FORMER
PRESIDENTS DON’T EVER ON THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT.
DO YOU THINK THAT’S TRUE, WHAT
WOULD THAT MEAN?
>> IS NOT THE THING THAT GUY
THAT I WORK FOR HAS NOT DONE
THAT BUT BILL CLINTON DID REALLY
TRY TO GO AFTER MITT ROMNEY, IN
2012.
AND IT WAS PRETTY SKILLFUL,
ACTUALLY, DOING SO.
THE OTHER THING BARACK OBAMA
APPARENTLY IS GOING TO TALK A
LOT ABOUT TONIGHT’S ACCUSER
REPUBLICANS OF VOTER SUPPRESSION
EFFORTS AND TO TELL YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY MUST RESIST
THIS, GET AROUND IT, GET OUT
THERE AND VOTE SO I THINK YOU
WILL EXPECT TO SEE THAT AND I
IMAGINE, YOU’LL BE TALKING ABOUT
IT ON YOUR SHOW TOMORROW NIGHT.